george steiner gehört zu der immer
seltener werdenden spezies des
universalgelehrten es gibt kaum ein
gebiet des geistes dass der 83-jährige
in seinen büchern nicht schon erforscht
und durchdachte religion kunst
philosophie literatur physik was denkt
ein mensch wie george steiner über das
alte und das neue europa gibt es eine
erotik des lesens und sind wir menschen
in den letzten 3000 jahren bezug auf die
zentralen fragen unserer existenz in
irgendeiner form weiter gekommen
fragen die juri steiner interessieren er
hat george steiner zum gespräch geladen
sehr geehrter herr steiner sie sind der
letzte große humanist hoffe nicht ich
ein bisschen traurig aber man sagt dass
aviva sie sie sind
literaturwissenschaftler kritiker
professor schriftsteller und sie sind in
mindestens vier sprachen zu hause
sie hatten mindestens 18 bücher 19
bilder bald veröffentlicht man nennt sie
professor ohne grenzen sie haben den
größten universitäten der welt gelehrt
in cambridge oxford yale am collège de
france und während 20 jahren in genf als
kosmopolit und als liebhaber der
klassischen europäischen literatur
sie nennen das den langen nachmittag
derart und ländlichen kultur sehen sie
heute auf europa ein europa das
zusammenbricht
nein das wäre sehr oberflächlich es ist
eine komplizierte krise aber schauen sie
es ist doch ein gottes wunder dass nach
zwei weltkriegen welche europäische
bürgerkriege waren im grund ihn ein
nach verlusten wo vielleicht 70
millionen menschen zwischen madrid und
care von leningrad hat sich doch europa
holt das wunder ist das nicht das europa
schwierigkeiten hat
aber das ist noch in europa gibt und
doch gibt es eines tages vielleicht
werden die historiker sagen im moment wo
sie und ich uns begegnen gab es ein
großer maler große dichter große denker
man kann nie vereinfachen
im nächsten gebäude in der nächsten
straße sitzt daher oder die dame die
vielleicht alles verwandeln können
es gibt noch sehr große kräfte in europa
eine sache tut mir tiefe schwarze sorgen
wir verlieren eine generation junger
leute die keine arbeit finden und wenn
man sich arbeit findet erholt man sich
vielleicht sehr schlecht in england
unsere besten junge leute wollen weg
aber wohin man kriegt keine arbeit
zulassungen kann allein neuseeland in
australien in spanien ein landwirt
richtig liebe ist es katastrophal 24
prozent der jungen sind arbeitslos auch
die begabtesten diese jungen leute
beginnen sich ja auch zu integrieren sie
sich zu revoltieren es gibt alle
occupy-bewegung wall street wird bereits
in zürich der prater platz in spanien
gibt es diese aber zu welchem ende weil
man kann sich in die knie aber wo bleibt
die antwort wo fragen stellen die jungen
haben komplett recht radikale fragen
böse fragen soll man stellen
aber wo sind die antworten es ist zu
leicht zu wollen dass der kapitalismus
und niedermacht ganz richtig aber zum
gulag wollen wir auch nicht zurück und
bis jetzt ist eine sozialistische
hoffnung eines dritten wegs diese
berühmte frage der dritte weg der cervis
wo ist sie es gibt kleine länder wie
norwegen zb wo es leichter ist wo man
eine wunde beizuziehen aber wie sie
wissen gerade jetzt zu einigen monaten
ein massenmord in norwegen kein land
ist in sicherheit andererseits es wird
aus asien
es werden große kräfte kommen zwei große
quellen frauen und asien frauen fangen
nur ganz langsam an sich zu bewerten
es ist kann da löw ich habe mein ganzes
leben gekämpft für frauen kollegen in
universität wir werden die schweiz nicht
besprechen aber in anderen ländern auch
in amerika setzen sie sich durch in
frankreich erstaunlicherweise kommen
frauen haben die spitze da ich eine
ungeheures reserve war psychologisch
philosophisch es hängt nur an die kraft
der frauen sich zu verklären
sie wollte nicht über die schweiz reden
aber wenn sie es doch tun
ich war immer ein glücklicher gastiert
es ist ein land welches dem gast sagt
wir nehmen dich und halt dass meiler
bisher aber dann darfst du arbeiten und
dann darfst du ein ruhiges leben haben
und dann darfst du deine abend und
sprachen sprechen
ich habe england ich habe aufgegeben in
cambridge wo es keine vergleichende
literatur gibt weil die engländer sagen
aber jemand alle leute sprechen englisch
warum soll ich eine fremdsprache wer da
ist eine art provinz nobis muss der
weltsprache ist ein paradox aber die
weltsprache ist auch provinz und die
sicherlich für mich in der schweiz zu
sein wo 45 mit dem reh tisch 56 sprache
doch zugelassen sind und wo man das
gefühl hat dass sich die alten kräfte
von europa begegnen
sie sind ja ein großer kulturvermittler
sie sind im alten europa auf die welt
gekommen wie in paris
sie haben in new york studiert sie sind
ein vermittler zwischen dem alten europa
und dem neuen vorwärts lassen
trainerkollege die hauptsache sagen es
gibt die großen dichter
romanschriftsteller dramaturgen die
leute die schaffen die großen treffen
und dann gibt es die leute wie ich die
briefträger da zitiere ich den
wunderbaren russischen dichter busch
gehen vorhin hat gesagt danke an meine
übersetzung
danke an die herr professor danke an
meine verleger aber ich schreibe die
brüche
richtig da sage ich mir wenn ich
aufstehe jeden morgen er schreibt den
brief ich habe in meinem leben das glück
gehabt ein briefträger zu sein
es gab ein wunderbar film namens post
kinos über neruda und seine gedichte der
briefträger musste richtige briefkasten
finden nicht immer leicht er muss sicher
sein dass der brief an kommt nicht immer
leicht es ist herrlich mit zu arbeiten
aber nie nie verwechseln der den den
brief schreibt und ich habe sie begegnen
jetzt sieht sich im gesegneten cambridge
in england im augenblick im augenblick
haben wir elf nobelpreisträger in diesem
kleinen doch elf nur beweist die riesen
der wissenschaft der astrophysik der
genetik der biologie wenn man diese
menschen ein bisschen begegnet und kämmt
dieses die wissen wie man die welt
ändert es ist sehr schön ein bisschen
dahinter zu laufen und sagen ich kann
erklären oder ich kann kommentieren oder
ich kann ein bisschen eine lektion
darüber geben aber nie die zwei
funktionen vermarktung
das ist die hauptsache aber sie sind sie
mit ihren kolleginnen cambridge er
zuversichtlich oder
ich bin im über die human use die
geistesgeschichte aber die
naturwissenschaften von jeder woche
kommt was dein geld sauber vor zwei
wochen ist die genetik der malaria
entziffert stellen sie sich vor
für 100 millionen menschen in afrika und
asien wird das ein neues leben in meinem
alter hat man eine tierische angst vor
beamte sie der demenz ja vor dem
alzheimer meine kollegen sagen wir
binnen zwei oder drei jahren wird man
die genetik des alzheimer scannen und
dann kann man anfangen zu kurieren jeden
tag was kommen die wunder in astrophysik
wir sind am an den rand des weltalls und
sie erraten neue welt neue ein neuer
kosmos entfaltet sich so man darf nicht
sagen nur die kunst nur die literatur
nur die philosophie diese in den sehr
schlechten zustand
aber nicht jede epoche kennt eine
bergspitze in den künsten oder im denken
es gar zehnten jahrhundert frankreich
lange lange generationen ohne einen
guten dichter dann kommen die
romantischen riesen kann sich auch holen
es gibt meines erachtens nach drei oder
vier sehr große englische maler becken
harte und kita und auerbach erstes mal
seit dem 16 jahrhundert und turner
turner war die einige die einzige
ausnahme
es gibt seit benjamin britten sehr gute
komponisten england hat nicht komponiert
über jahrhunderte
wir verstehen sehr wenig vom zauber der
neu erwachten die ferien kommen und man
und man öffnet die augen
der zauber der neuer wache das ist eine
sehr schöne metapher für glaube ich ihre
biografie zu welchem moment in ihrem
leben haben sie diesen zauber eines
überhaupt an
gespielt da stellen sie eine sehr tiefe
und schwierige frage
ich habe in chicago die hoffnung
naturwissenschaften und sein
meine mathematik hat nicht dazu gelangt
es war der moment der kernphysik und
wenn man nicht gut da mathematiker war
gab es keine offene tür
so habe ich traurig philosophie und
politik angefangen aber die nostalgie
für die naturwissenschaften habe mich
nie verlassen
und wissen sie die zürich ist die stadt
der eth nie vergessen was die großen
leistungen her sind dann kam wunderbare
augenblick wo das lesen für mich
entscheidend wurde und wo ich angefangen
habe selbst zu schreiben und zu
übersetzen
sie werden über mich lachen macht nichts
jeden morgen jeden morgen sonntag
einbegriffen nämlich vom ein buch
welches es auch sei dem eine 34 setzte
einen bagger und übertrage sehen meine
anderen sprachen als übung der seele
aber auch als mussten übung ich glaube
dass das bewusstsein ein muster ist und
werden wir im vernachlässigt wird der
schlaf holen
ich spiel sehr schlecht aber
leidenschaftlich schach so dass die
konzentration ausgabe
wir vergessen alle was für ungeheure
macht das gedächtnis hat welche unsere
konzentration möglichkeiten beim ernsten
lesen sind aber man muss üben wo wenn
man alt ist muss man noch mehr üben und
wie war es als ganz ganz jung waren wie
sind sie zum lesen gekommen ich hatte
ein unglück ein vater ein gesegneter
vater der mit mir gelesen habe und ich
erzähle immer die anekdote wir lesen in
der großen fonds übertragung ins
deutsche
die ilias kommt ein
ultra dramatischer moment wird achilles
den legalen nieder hauen mein vater mit
einer ganz traurigen mienen sagte mir
mein kleiner hier haben wir keine
besetzung die fehlt was werden wir tun
du willst doch wissen ob die leute
ständig an
da müssen wir griechisch lernen sie so
hat es angefangen
einige worte für ein kind kam das total
entscheidend sein
hab mir gesagt ich will wissen was da
vorgeht und geschichten erzählen
geschichten lieben ist wahrscheinlich
der anfang
man hat dafür ein sehr pompös lord nato
logi um brauchen wir nicht einfach
gesunder der geschichte was geschieht
nicht
wie haben sie es mit ihren eigenen
kindern gehabt und haben sie denn auch
die odyssee vorgelesen aufsicht sein
eigenen kindern auch aber die sind jetzt
ganz erwachsen sind erwachsene und tun
wäre meine tochter dirigiert das fach
der alten der altertumswissenschaft in
columbia
mein schwiegersohn ist er professor für
lateinische dichtung in princeton
mein sohn ist dekan einer großen
universität new york
es geht gut weiter es gilt gut war aber
in amerika sieht die sache ganz anders
das was wir einen rat für kinder lektüre
würden sie einem normalen ehepaar geben
dass ein normal begabtes kind ich glaube
ganz am die große neben der antike ilias
und odyssee sind unübertrefflich
aufregend unübertrefflich spannen jeden
moment aber dann
es gibt bücher der bibel die natürliche
die höchsten die von der menschheit sind
der menschlichen vorstellung wenn man
ganz langsam
sie nehmen ein großes episode david
könig david wächst auf erkämpft gegen
seoul und jonathan
sein bester freund ist der sohn seines
landes der jonathan wird getötet und das
sind es war ein gesamt der david den
totes gesang über jonathan und seitdem
ist die trauer im westen eine große
politik seit diesem augenblick dann ich
vergleiche am selben tisch schlage ich
dem kind jetzt werden die akkus hören
wie der über patroklos weint den tools
machen und dann sage ich dem kind beide
diese texte sind ganz ultramodern jetzt
wären wir einen wirklich alten das buch
gilgamesch auszumachen wo gilgamesch
über enke du weinte erste große lametta
zion in der westlichen literatur und da
sagte ich glaube ich das kind ist das
nicht fantastisch dass es überlebt hat
und dann habe ich immer und auch meinen
schülern meine studenten versucht zu
erklären die magie des überlebens
herr kollege wenn in st gallen in
unserem schönen st gallen er wenn die
lombardischen truppen nicht 12 km 12
gelingt gegen sie vorbei wenn sie st
gallen entdeckt hätten und
niedergebrannt hätten wir kaum ein hurra
zu beginn und gratuliert alles war dort
oft in einem einzigen exemplar der
richtig ist die mönche abend und
buchstaben für buchstaben mit kleinen
kerzen abgeschrieben haben dass da sind
das überleben der großen texte und auch
der modernen texte dass wir haben jetzt
ganz große schriftsteller werden die in
einer neuen technologischen fassung
überleben das ist eine sehr schwierige
frage
diese frage auch in einem schmalen
bändchen zu behandeln versucht und mit
den neuen medien man merkt dass auch
gerungen die die bücher verbrennen wer
sind die die die bücher verbrennen
man verbrennt bücher seit dem anfang der
geschichte
große bibliothek in alexandria nur die
frauen in sarajevo vor wenigen jahren
hat man die bibliothek verbrannt und da
sind 168 manuskripte man nennt sie
inkunabeln für die es keine kopie
gegeben hat weil sarajevo nicht reicher
und konnte noch nicht online gehen
wurden für immer zerstört denken sie
dann für immer wenn eine wahrheit aus
der welt verschwindet da da will ich
erlauben sie mir eine sekunde langsam zu
reden weil es ist eine etwas seltsame
idee wahrheiten können verschwinden
es gab die furchtbaren albicans hier
kreuzzüge im süden von frankreich
als die mittelalterliche kirche eine
höhere sie ausgerottet hat
es bleibt uns kein einziger text ich
sagte mir manchmal und wenn ja begannen
sie eine große wahrheit entdeckt und wir
es wahrheiten können verschwinden
man sagt jemand anders wird das
entdecken ich glaube in den radio
wissenschaft ja wenn da nicht gegen wäre
käme walsrode jemand 30 jahre später
lange nach keppler und newton kamen
andere aber nicht in der philosophie ein
gedicht welches verbrannt ist für immer
wird es nie wieder geben
das ist ja so ist es ganz zentral wenn
man sie liest ist ja der übergang von
einer oralen tradition zu einer
schriftlichen tradition kultur und wenn
sie über die neuen medien schreiben
erzählen sie auch dass wir vielleicht
wieder zurückfallen in eine mündliche
kurzem ein nein ich sehe gar nicht junge
kinder mit ipad und facebook
und es ist eine orale kultur sie
sprechen zueinander
sie komponieren geschichten zueinander
witze allerlei einer kultur des bund und
desto mehr ist ultra mutter hat noch
mehr ist wie joyce
vorher gab es wahrscheinlich 20.000
jahren einer großen mündlichen literatur
er kommt spät für den größten aller
philosophen platon ist das eine
katastrophe weil das menschliche
gedächtnis wir zwar geschwächt durch die
schrift weil die schrift will autoritär
sein
sie lässt keine keine angriff keine
keine instanz keine moment are antwort
die das schrift das mündliche gibt es
eine antwort eine provokation eine
verbesserung man kann nein sagen es ist
sehr schwer dem buch nein zu sagen
den wahrheiten verschwinden können kommt
noch etwas anderes was ihnen sehr am
herzen liegt so wie sie es sagen das
auswendiglernen da da bin ich ein ganz
altmodische bekannt ich glaube fanatisch
anders auswendig lernen warum das
deutsche wort auswendig verfehlt die
ganze platte man sagt auf englisch bei
harten herzen
man sagt in französisch sprachige mit
dem herzen nicht mit dem gehirn was man
auswendig lernt liebt man es wird teil
uns selbst es lebt in uns fast organisch
es verwandelt sich mit uns wenn ich mir
jetzt meine gedichte aus dem
französischen lithium wenn ich mir jetzt
einige werke von racine
ich kenne sehr viele französische und
englische gedichte auswendig habe ich
plötzlich jedes mal den eindruck 8 uhr
entdeckt dass wieder da ist etwas ganz
neues weil du dich verändert hast und es
verändert sich in dir und dann eine
politische bemerkung wir leben in einer
zeit der grausamsten zensur in den
despotischen starten
wir haben den stalinismus gekannt den
maoismus den narzissen was man auswendig
kennt habt eine chance zu überleben
die dichtung von dem russischen dichter
lyrischen dichter ossip mandelstam seine
witze hat jedes gedicht an acht freunde
mündlich vermittelt sie haben das
gedicht auswendig gelernt wenn acht
leute ein gedicht kennen ist es
unzerstörbar und so hat das werk
überlebt bis der stalinismus endlich zu
ende ging
es ist eine ungeheure reserve im
menschlichen gehirn und die freude die
freude einem text danke zu sagen
jedes mal dass sich ein gericht von
hölderlin lese und ein bisschen
auswendig sehr sehr schwierig man
versucht eine strophe dass ich schon
etwas da sage ich danke
weil wie in welcher anderen art kann ich
mich bei dem dichter endlos bedanken
er macht mir ein geschenk ich kann ihm
nicht dafür zeigt kann nicht belohnen
ich möchte danke sagen fans eine strophe
von hinter wien natürlich die die die
die blumen denen den kalten wasser
hängen
das wurde mittels leben und wo die
fahnen zu klären
die farm entleeren in den keller das ist
eins der allerschönsten und die zweite
ist das zweite ko sagt am antigone
vieles gibt es ungeheuer aber das
ungeheuer ist es der mensch so fängt es
an heiliger hat gesagt mit diesen versen
hat sich der westliche schicksal
entschieden das ist eine schöne
übertreibung aber nicht ganz sie haben
vor kurzem darüber geredet eben das
jesus christus zb man weiß nicht ob
geschrieben hat dass er nicht
geschrieben gelesen gelesen wer war
sicher nicht aber sicherlich als
analphabeten galilei zu seiner zeit wenn
man nicht ganz reich war oder im
priesterlichen stamm war man analphabet
sokrates war vielleicht wir haben einen
moment an
man nennt es müssen technischen wort ein
passus wo sich auf eine schriftliche
rolle beruf nur einmal in allen unseren
dialogen
er singt er vor dem tode kennt den fabel
dichter aesop auswendig und sagt ich
werd dazu jetzt singen und aber nichts
von einem buch und könnte man sagen dass
dann vielleicht diese neue mündliche
zivilisation die mit ipods kindern ein
kind aber ipod arbeit dass die einfach
den bogen schlagen wieder zurück ich
habe angst das ist die sachen zu leicht
macht das ist um ernst zu lesen braucht
man schweigen konzentration und nicht
angst haben vor der einsamkeit und ich
liebe das die welt meiner kinder in
amerika ich bin jeden tag froh dass sie
dort sind weil ich glaube für juden gibt
es keine andere zukunft gut anderes
problem aber michael facebook rasch
leicht in gekürzter fassung und ob man
wieder liest ist sehr problematisch aber
ich kann mich ihren als guttenberg seine
große entdeckung gemacht hat haben die
leute gesagt hast das ende des buchs
papiers billig die tinte fährt darf
meine ich will noch meine manuskripte
haben und die 82 jahre wo man noch sehr
viele manuskripte geschrieben hat wir
sind zu am anfang dieser neuen welt und
es ist eine neue welt
der herr steve jobs ist gerade gestorben
und der vergleich mit er dessen ist ganz
berechtigt es ist eine neue welt haben
sie selbst ein ipod nein aber ich
erkläre nicht aus aus dummheit und
snobismus aber die augen gewöhnen sich
schlecht daran und ich liebe den geruch
eines buch ich schnuppere bücher ich
liebe das ja dass christ christ christes
papier sein
ich liebe denn ein band einer schönen
buch es ist für mich eine art sexualität
des lesens und das nein ich habe keinen
ipod aber bitte im fall von unfall von
von katastrophen spitalbesuch das neue
wunder eines mobile phone das rettet
viele leben es recht viele familien
beziehung man muss gerecht sein es ist
eine neue welt kommt heraus und wo es wo
man das nicht den reichtum hat um große
bibliotheken zu gründen für das neue
afrika für die neuen universitäten
asiens league entscheidend werden können
sie über eine generation springend und
sich am ipod am kinder an am schirm eine
bibliothek schaffen was über nacht
denken sie an was das bedeutet für die
schüler für die forscher und für die
lehrer aber sie sagen man braucht eben
viel ruhe viel zeit abgeschiedenheit um
zu lesen um einen text sich anzueignen
ins herzen zu schließen und diese
beziehung aufzubauen
haben wir überhaupt noch diese zeit ich
bin so verwöhnt sie werden müssen nicht
mehr nicht glauben ich habe eine große
bibliothek ist die bücher hat ich hab
ganz wenig wahrscheinlich 5000er malen
mein freund der große umberto eco hat
30.000 in seiner wohnung in mihla 37 ich
habe ungefähr 5
ich habe in meinem schönen englischen
garten ein kleines arbeitszimmer wo ich
in totale ruhe niemand darf mich stören
ist ein wunderbarer moment im modernen
der große trotzig eine der größten
lesende geschichte er hat sich im turm
verriegelt und hat gesagt frau und
kinder sind störung
es war nicht ganz ernst aber so kommt
der arbeiten in totale ruhe lesen und
arbeiten auch in totale ruhe in musik
hören
für mich ist es unvorstellbar dass man
ernste musik hört und liest zur selben
zeit dass man im ohr die drähte hat und
ein buch vor sie und für die jungen ist
es selbstverständlich
man liest nur wenn man dazu musik an und
man die jungen besonders in den
industriellen staaten wie amerika aber
auch die chinesen haben eine mords angst
vor der einsamkeit allein zu sein ist
asozial ist in einer art ist ist eine
art meuterei gegen die menschliche
gemeinschaft aber man muss lernen allein
zu sein
ich hatte großen vorteil den
schriftsteller und kämpfer castro gut zu
kennen dessen sonnen finden es wichtig
die geschichte verändert hat ja gesagt
wenn man nicht weiß was es im gefängnis
zu sitzen und auf ein buch zu warten
weiß man nicht was wirkliche
schwierigkeiten ist in der einsamkeit
und man überlebt und man lernt allerlei
künste des innenlebens
wir unterschätzen so furchtbar die
reserven der innerlichen kräfte
sie sind ungeheuer wenn sie momentan
jetzt genannt haben das war ja nicht wie
sie ein frauen vater in diesem fall wenn
er gesagt hat ohne frauen und kinder
nein es war eine zeit und da öffnen sie
ein sehr großes kapitel wann haben
und angefangen ernst zu lesen wann
hatten sie die zeit wann hatten sie die
privat möglichkeit ein buch zu besitzen
in der klassischen welt achtzehnte
jahrhundert frankreich auch in weimar
hatten frauen keinen zutritt zu den
großen bibliotheken zum beispiel eine
andere revolution jetzt fand die frau an
gott sei gelobt zu lesen
es hat große frauen dichter gegeben
einige riesen im roman wird jeder wurf
jr george sand aber wenig große
leserinnen die zeit noch einmal dieses
braucht eben für diese liebe zur
literatur gibt es dann auch liebe auf
den ersten blick ein buch das man sofort
spontan sie haben total recht dass sie
sich sehr seltsames die hand weiß etwas
was das gehirn nicht weil man greift
nach einem buch ich war am bahnhof in
frankfurt zwischen zügen
dazu hatte drei oder vier minuten
verspätung
ich stehe am kiosk ich sehe ein ganz
schmalen band mit einem namen seltsamen
namen paul celan ade nie den namen
gehört ich blättere und komme auf den
wer eine sprache im norden der zukunft
blitz trifft mich bemüht hat mein leben
verändert und das anfang meiner
leidenschaftlichen verwicklung mit
auszuleihen und seinem schicksal
reine show im kiosk am bahnhof viele der
großen entdeckungen war menschen die an
einen tee in paris vorbeischlendern luft
lange und in dem buch schachteln sehen
sie für einige fans etwas ganz
entscheidendes und man muss nie sich
schämen darf das unterstreichen sei es
ein krimi sei es ein western was man
liebt dessen darf man sich schämen
eln ideen snobismus der elite haben nein
es gibt entscheiden den leseabenteuer
mit kitschigen büchern und es ist sehr
schwer zu analysieren was das schlechte
gute buch ist das ist eine wichtige
kategorie es gibt schlechte gute bücher
die ganz entscheidend sind nichts neues
im westen von re/max von jedem
literarischen stammt aus wirklich sehr
schwach aber bitte so blöd sind das so
sagen es hat millionen leben verändert
und es gibt clubs die für viele leute
die erste begegnung ist mit einer
anderen welt nie nie nie protzen mit
büchern nicht alle leute lesen immanuel
kant ist es denn schwierig heute für sie
ein buch zu klassifizieren zu sagen das
ist der neue dante das ist der neue güte
und das darf man kaum weil man wird sich
ihr mann wird sich skandalös und
blamabel er aber doch es gibt einige
riesen heute wo man ganz sicher sein
kann es gibt ein romane sich überall
hier in zürich auch in taschen leben und
schicksal von von grossmann und lange
worden der ist ganz so groß wie torres
tores krieg und frieden ist eine selbe
dimension
es gibt natürlich ganz große dichter
nicht nur zelaya bonn vor in frankreich
eine schar ts eliot montage es gibt sehr
große italienische dichter
da darf man mehr oder wenig sicher sein
aber macht nichts wenn man sich erdmann
sich es gibt ein wichtiger aufsatz ein
langer von balzac und ball sagt glauben
sie mir hat etwas vom mauer an vorstand
und da schreibt über seinen bekannten
den konsul in civitavecchia mit den
namen start alles war natürlich ein dorn
im auge
wer über das rote und der schwarze und
sehr sagte ein sehr begabter amateur
roman sehr begabt aber im vergleich mit
den schauder romanen von etlichen leicht
wird es nicht dauern sagt gar keine
chancen
balzac wer hat sich etwas was ihr macht
gar nichts markt gar nicht besser sich
zu verlieren als prätentiös versuchen
dass man besondere antennen hat es gibt
menschen die für neue kunst ganze
staunte antennen haben
es gab eine ganz kleine anzahl in der
schweiz die verstanden haben das
powerplay eine neue welt entdeckt ganz
wenige mama es braucht zeit und ich sage
es wieder nur wenn man sich irrt ist
doch wirklichkeit verbrechen mann war
zumindest verliebten texte er und man
hört sich mit frauen man ist verliebt
und das ist die falsche wie begegnen sie
denn wenn man jetzt die sanitas ein
bisschen weiter sich mit dem
verliebtsein wenn man verliebt ist dann
sieht man etwas besonderes an für ein
rennteam wie lesen sie weil lesen sie es
gibt eine erotik des lesens aber da muss
man sehr aufpassen
das stimmt wahrscheinlich viel weniger
für große philosophen
ich würde mich nicht wagen in hegel
verliebt zu sein
er würde mir einen guten tritt in den
hintern geben er wollte nicht geliebt
sein er wurde verstanden sein
es gibt mit dem kapital von marx wo man
nur den ersten band liest verliebt zu
sein ist ein bisschen schwer aber noch
was für ein buch was wenn titanen buch
nein aber mit den roman und mit den
dichtern sich in einen dichten verlieben
als ich noch für cambridge
die eintrittspreis habe ich den jungen
immer gesagt erzählen sie mir gibt es
ein schriftsteller den sie sammeln den
sie genug lieben alle seine werke zu
haben sogar die schlechten
das ist das wichtige unter den titanen
gibt es menschen die auch schlechte
bücher geschrieben haben ich nenne nur
einen konrad hat einige sehr aber was
macht aber man liebt den man will auch
die schlechte bücher haben und es sind
sehr schwache bücher von graham greene
aber auch sehr große und man sammelt
weil das sammeln ist auch eine form von
liebe sie haben kürzlich in einem
interview gesagt dass mich beschäftigt
hat das wenn man so viel liest wenn man
sich so vertieft in die literatur
dann haben sie manchmal angst sagen sie
dass sie etwas nicht hören was darum
herum den fersen sie das erwähnen
man kommt nach hause nach einem langen
tag arbeiten und ich müde möglich beim
man vertieft sich einen entdeckt man
hört nicht den schrei in der straße sein
wird sehr sehr genau
es ist nicht dass man ihn nicht hören
will man hört ihn nicht wenn man sagen
wir mit den dritten und vierten aufzug
vom king lear lebt kein schreien der
straße kann sich mit dem schrei im text
zu vergleichen
so habe ich oft ich habe das in meinen
schriften den cordelia problem genannt
wenn man die torte cordelia in den armen
hält hört man nicht das leben und das
ist sehr gefährlich
ich fange an als ganz junger ganz junger
kritiker meine ersten versuche am abend
spielt man schubert am morgen fordert
man wie ist das möglich habe nie eine
antwort gefunden bin jetzt in meinen
achtziger jahren keine antwort ich habe
alles gefragt an die psychologen die
soziologen unsinn kein wir verstehen das
nicht zu sagen dass die menschen es geht
so fremde sind antwortet nicht was ist
es welches in der großen musik gehabt
auch in der literatur jenseits von guten
und bösen nietzsches rosa titel jenseits
von gut und böse
es ist in einen anderen bereich der
werte sind nicht menschliche werte und
unter den größten künstler gab es leute
dessen benehmen aber furchtbar war
wir werden nicht den fall hat wagner
besprechen
ich konnte nicht wirklich mein leben
führen ohne den tristan ohne den ring
ohne den zweiten akt von parzival
aber der herr wagner das ist ein anderes
kapitel
und wie ist das möglich wie hat diese
diese frage die sie nicht beantworten
können ihr eigenes politisches
bewusstsein beeinflusst ich habe und ich
schäme mich keine politik betrieben ich
habe mich nicht aktiv geteilt ich war
teils das wandern teils die die lage den
aber ich hätte wahrscheinlich nicht mehr
mitteilen sollen aristoteles ist sehr
sehr grausam damit er sagt wenn du zu
hause bleiben wirst und nicht in den
forum gehst auf den öffentlichen markt
zur politik dann hast du kein recht sich
über die schurken und barbaren zu
beschweren
wo warst du du hast dein privatleben
gewählt dass eine sehr schwere anlage
leiden sie darunter dass diesen schritt
jetzt aber es war nie praktisch möglich
und dadurch und da ich immer ein rammt
mensch war ich habe es gewählt ich habe
gewählt und immer in bewegung war hatte
sich nicht gestaltet diese marginale
existenz auch als professor hat ja auch
innerhalb des systems der universität ja
auch ebenso ja deswegen außenstehenden
figur ich hasse die bürokratie die
meisten dekane sind die todfeinde der
zivilisation
ich habe immer war die universität
gefragt warum tun wir es nicht besser
und das macht man sich nicht beliebt und
wir haben vorher davon gesprochen wenn
man sich als postino als briefträger
das haben die kollegen gar nicht gern
die kollegen sind schon dass die stolz
auf ihre die meisten auf ihre
parasitären künste und die haben
wirklich nicht gern dass man ihnen
erklärt sie sind die früher im domäne
des löwens haben sie studenten
studentinnen gehabt von denen sie
gemerkt haben dass sie besser sind ja
also dachte ich wie groß der bünte
größte belohnung
ich habe mehr als 50 jahre gelehrt und
ab vier student das ist viel gehabt die
viel begabtere sind als ich und dessen
schicksal ich verfolge es von großem
interesse zwei sind sehr berühmte
professoren geworden
eine wein kämpfte begabteste von allen
und er ist dem rauschgift fall und das
ist eine sache von der man sich als
lehrer nie ganz erholt und führte war
eine junge frau die tochter eines meiner
bergarbeiters kommt als erste aus ihrem
dorf nach cambridge und hat die höchste
auszeichnung summa cum laude und der
universitäts preis
komm zu mir um auf wiedersehen zu sagen
sie haben mir nur scheiß entschuldigen
nur scheiße beigebracht für sie und
diese universität habe ich nur hohn
jetzt fängt mein leben ab und sie wurde
erst den mann hat sie geht nimmt die
ärzte ohne schuhe in sexual im
westlichen china unter den total verarmt
sie war mau ist in total melden und da
kann ich nur den mund halten
jemand der sein leben für eine ideologie
gibt um andere menschen zu helfen
in den entlegendsten bergdörfern des
westlichen china
das ist die höchste so wenn sie wollen
zivilisation für das habe ich nicht die
kraft
er ist sehr schade ich bedauere es sehr
dass diese junge frau mir nicht viel
zeit hat alles sich dann professor war
gastprofessorin bashing habe ich den
englischen botschaft nur darüber nach
sagt oh ja unsere geheimdienste wissen
genau wo sie ist
sie will auch mit uns nichts zu tun
haben
aber da ich hasse salon märtyrer
ich hasse salon marxisten die nie nach
russland im saloon zionisten die nie die
nase reinstecken würden aber wenn man
sein leben gibt wenn man seinen glauben
lebt seinen glauben leben
dann bin ich voll tiefster achtung diese
existenzielle freiheit die sie
beschreiben
bei dieser schülerin diese freiheit hat
mit dem denken zu tun dass sie
vielleicht als als briefträger bei ihr
auch entfacht haben und für sich selbst
erklären sie auch das denken zwar
befreit aber denken auch traurig macht
und sie haben dieses ja ein kleines
puzzle aber sei ein großer erfolg war
und sich tausendmal verkraften in der
deutschen sichern ein buch welches auf
der deutschen philosophischen tradition
herstammt
die problem das schöne lateinische wort
trifft dies ja das ist mehr als das ist
mehr als kränkung mehr als trauer
es ist eine art müdigkeit der seele
eine art trägheit der seele auch die
seele wird manchmal müde und eine
schwieriges denken ein denken ohne
antworten ein denken wir uns vor der tür
bleibt kafkas groß ich habe vom torhüter
kann auch traurig machen und es gibt
große traurige denker kirkegaard war ein
es gibt auch viele andere unter den
theologen es gibt große traurige denke
es gibt seiten über die traurigkeit in
pascal die ganz mit dostojewski mit
beschenkt sich vergleichen aber ich
besser zu denken und ein bisschen
traurig zu sein was mich sehr erstaunt
seite setzt das privileg habe sie
kennengelernt zu haben ist das wenn man
das buch liest warum denken traurig
macht denkt man einen sehr traurigen
zeitgenossen vor finden zu müssen und
wenn man sie sieht und ihre lebenslust
und ihre spielfreude merkt dann denkt
man das müsste das geht doch nicht
zusammen
doch es gilt zu sammeln weil man ich
komme zurück auf die dankbarkeit vor den
währt die freude die und sein konzert
bringt eine ausstellung ich habe jetzt
schwierigkeiten karten gekauft studi
leonardo da vinci ausstellung in london
die menschen stehen schlange über nacht
in der kalten nacht in der hoffnung eine
karte zu finden
er ist doch herrlich mit diesem endlosen
reichtum sich aus 190 stellen und der
moment wenn man etwas neues lernt da
haben die naturwissenschaftler den
großen
vorteil heute wissen sie weniger als
nächsten donnerstag
nächsten donnerstag werden sie etwas
wissen was sie heute noch nicht wissen
das laufende band geht so in den human
lloris ist es viel schwieriger aber dort
auch kann man immer vor neues lesen
ich bin sehr sehr faul geworden über
sprachen sehr faul bitte ich hätte um
den riesen dichter portugiesischen
dichter person der der einer der titanen
ist um die übersetzungen sind sehr
schwächt schreiber da hat mir ein
kollege gesagt hat war lerner bisserl
wort du dich ganz recht hatte ich habe
es nicht gemacht man wird fall stinkt
sagt man und das bedauere ich sehr
aber weiter arbeiten jeden morgen aber
sie tun sich ja nicht nur die ganz
großen die titanen an und zieht es nicht
nur um ehre und sie uns sehen sondern
sie lesen auch harry potter und ich bin
für das harry potter phänomen absolut
fasziniert der roman ist ultra englisch
aber ultra es ist ein was man ein public
school romanen der wortschatz ist reich
die grammatik ist oft schwierig eskimo
kinder stehen die nacht lang für die
ersten exemplare die metallionen in
alaska landen in zulu ist es der
bestseller jedes judo die man am raulin
die eine reizende bescheidene frau ich
sagte ich verstehe nicht sie hat bis
jetzt 600 millionen und 600 mann hat für
harry potter eine bank gegründet nur für
harry potter was erklärt die
phänomenologie eines welterfolg und die
kinder lesen es wieder sechs dicke bände
und viele kinder fangen wieder vom
anfang an
niemand versteht und um es zu
verallgemeinern
wir haben keinen max weber des
bestsellers wir brauchen einen großen
denker und soziologen um uns die
phänomenologie des bestsellers zu
erklären besteht in der jetzigen
aktuellen akuten wirtschaftskrise eine
direkte gefahr für die weiterentwicklung
der kultur
es ist eine frage die große sorgen
bringt
lassen sie mich einen augenblick über
engel ansprechen die kleinen
buchhandlungen schließen die compact
disc buchhandlungen und die klassische
musik schließen die kleinen theater
schließen in der provinz wo sie lebens
spendend waren es gibt richtige
zeitschriften mit sehr kleiner version
leserschaft die schließen
schon gibt es allerlei verluste weil man
nicht mehr die möglichkeit weil
hochkultur auch ein luxus ist der von
wohlstand und reichtum abhängt was eine
oper kostet brauche ich ihnen nicht zu
sagen und die menschen denen es jetzt an
allen fehlt werden sehr wütend sagen
warum sollen unsere steuern für kochen
gar die opferzahlen und uns fehlt es am
alltäglichen man schließt in
universitäten auch am kontinent fächer
zum beispiel griechisch latein
es gibt ganze schulen die schließen für
die klassische altertumswissenschaft in
einer der besten schottischen
universitäten gibt es keine philosophie
mehr mann verkleidet das soziale studien
kommunikation dieses urteil war
juni patience dort ist wo es einmal
ernste philosophie da ja ich habe große
angst
amerika ist noch relativ relativ
geschützt die großen amerikanischen
bibliotheken sammeln leute die großen
amerikanischen sinfonieorchester neue
öffnen in neuen städten
ob das dauern wird man sucht dort viele
quellen der hoffnung ohne zweifel aber
es ist auch im zeit zum teil unsere
schuld wir haben nicht laut genug
gebuhlt wir haben nicht genug gewissen
mit unseren zähnen
diddy diddy bonzen der kultur
verteidigen sich sehr schlecht also das
heißt wir beißen uns in die zukunft
brüllen und weisen als letztes thema
unseres gesprächs du dich sie sehr gerne
auf das judentum ansprechen ein ganz
zentrales thema für ihr leben und ihr
werk ich hatte fantastische glück in 40
aus frankreich zu einkommen in meiner
liste klasse ist nur ein anderer juden
kommen alle anderen wurden vergast
fantastisches blöd mit dem ich mich nie
ab finde ich verdanke die tradition des
buchs sie ich verdanke die hohe
schätzung des lehrer das wort rabbiner
heißt ein fachlehrer nicht richter
manier sie seien lehrer rabatt für mein
vater weiß wirklich hauptsächlich dass
sich lehrer werde weil er heißt die
sachen weiter gegeben und ich verdanke
natürlich vielleicht dieser 5000 jahre
alten kultur eine art kontrakt mit dem
leben
dass sie seien eine dumme phrase aber
eine art pakt mit dem leben zu versuchen
weiter zu leben und die tiefsten sachen
judentum sind witze die alle tiefsten
sagen ganz so tief wie die thora so alle
haben sie mir einen zu erzählen sehr
sehr sonntagmorgen gott erklärt er hat
genug von der menschheit solche schweine
sadisten sich so benehmen diesmal die
sind gut ist definitiv kein ohr keine
arche der heilige vater der papst sagt
an katholiken bitte die familien an sein
beten an die jungfrau maria und und
ruhig gottes uhr tragen die protestanten
sagen familien samen alle bankkonto
bitte in ordnung zu stellen
alle rechnungen zu bezahlen und dann der
rabbiner sagt zehn tage aber bitte das
ist mehr zeit das man braucht um zu
lernen unter wasser zu leben
um dieser herrliche witz unter wasser zu
atmen
das ist für mich der kanonische moment
fast schon jeden tag in meiner existenz
das heißt sie haben gelernt unter wasser
zu altern
ja
steiner ich danke ihnen sehr herzlich
für dieses gespräch
vielen dank
[Musik]
dieses gespräch sehen sie auf unserer
website wann immer sie wollen
dort können sie auch unseren newsletter
bestellen oder aber sie kaufen das
gespräch mit george steiner auf dvd
unter folgender adresse schweizer radio
und fernsehen redaktions sternstunden 80
52 zürich ihre e mail erreichte uns
unter stern kobinet srf punkt ch die
geburt und der tod gehören zum leben
doch wie bewusst gehen wir mit dem
drohenden ende um warum wird der tod
immer noch tabuisiert nächsten sonntag
gehen wir diesen fragen nach heute aber
geht es weiter mit musik und harte
arbeit vom zürcher opernstudio auf die
großen bühnen der welt der film zeigt
wie intensiv junge talente für die
schönheit ihrer stimme arbeiten
[Musik]
notenkenntnisse stimmt technik und
talent sind nur ein kleiner teil dessen
was einen überzeugenden opernsänger eine
überzeugende opernsängerin ausmachen
den entscheidenden anderen teil aus
jungen hochbegabten opern aspiranten
hervorzuholen
das hat sich das internationale
opernstudio in zürich zur aufgabe
gemacht bis vor kurzem noch unter der
künstlerischen leitung von alexander
pereira weltweit begehrt sind die
ausbildungsplätze und in wenigen denen
es gelingt einen davon zu ergattern
steht ein anstrengendes jahr bevor die
filmemacherin sabine gisiger hat drei
von zwölf jahrgang schülern auf ihrem
weg begleiten